the bolt gun is perhaps Warhammer 40
000's most iconic weapon yet it's up
until now for a video game to really
nail its pulverizing impact the space
Marine's Bolter as it's commonly known
is not the machine gun equivalent it's
often portrayed as in other games this
powerful firearm is essentially a
rapid-fire rocket launcher capable of
penetrating almost any armor and then
blowing up the imperium's enemies from
the inside out developer aurog digital
clearly understood the assignment with
Warhammer 40 000 bolt gun as the
eponymous weapon is tremendously fun to
use as you rip and tear your way through
eight hours of 90s inspired first-person
shooting the Bolter Roars with an
emphatic ratchet and each pull of the
trigger packs An Almighty punch
ferociously propelling these explosive
rounds through flesh and Bone until the
battlefield is little more than a
crimson pile of viscera and sinewy
chunks
all right
classic retro Shooters like Unreal
Tournament and Quake are obvious
Inspirations behind ball guns fast-paced
and frenetic combat but it's the
original Doom that feels like the
principal source of reverence the use of
2D Sprites alongside 3D environments
color-coded key card hunting and garage
over-the-top violence all hearken back
to its software seminal title bulk gun
is unashamedly a doomclon with a
Warhammer skin but auroch has sprinkled
in some Modern touches too from the
dizzying amount of particle effects on
screen at any one time to the intricate
level of detail found on each and every
weapon to the sheer scale of some of its
environments verticality is also heavily
emphasized with a jump and mantle
animation giving you the chance to
scramble and leap off of Ledges much
like in 2016's Doom reboot all of this
leads to bulk on managing to capture a
tangible sense of nostalgia while also
tapping into the fluidity and pace of a
contemporary shooter it's a familiar but
potent mix resulting in a viscerally
satisfying game that's relatively easy
to pick up and play the story is
suitably poultry however providing just
enough setup to explain why you're on a
distant planet mulling down anything
that breathes in the name of the
Inquisition as battle-hardened Space
Marine malam Cato you're dispatched to
the adeptis mechanicus Forge World of
graya to investigate some concerning
goings-on as it turns out the ad Mech
were running experiments that have
predictably gone awry and spawned a
chaos Invasion after a botched Landing
leaves you as the Lone Survivor you're
put to work cleansing the forces of
chaos armed with an ever expanding
supply of powerful weaponry
bolt guns assortment of 41st Millennium
armaments is at the heart of everything
great about its fast-paced action
there's no denying that the titular
Bolter is the star of the show but every
other weapon proves its worth making
this one of the more appealing arsenals
in the genre if you're not a Warhammer
fan having no prior knowledge isn't a
barrier to entry in any way but those
who are will appreciate the attention to
detail as each weapon looks and
functions as it should the plasma gun
for instance is extremely deadly but
volatile it might deal massive damage
but it's also prone to overheating at
which point it can malfunction and hurt
you too the melta gun on the other hand
unleashes an energetic beam of heat that
can dissolve armor in a heartbeat
proving especially useful against
tenacious enemies like the imposing
chaos Terminators even the chain sword
which is always available as a melee
option can cut through the toughest foes
given enough time part of what makes
each of these murderous tools so fun to
use is the tremendous audio and visual
feedback across the board
guns feel Hefty and consume the
soundscape with a cacophony of whirling
thermal energy thunderous Bedlam and the
clink of spent casings crashing against
the ground
basic enemies go down in one or two
shots and almost everything explodes on
death leaving behind Buckets of Blood
and heretical failure ammunition for the
most powerful weapons in Your Arsenal is
relatively scarce however which ensures
that the ball gun remains a consistent
companion throughout your journey The
Balter was my go-to when dealing with
cannon fodder enemy types such as human
cultists and swarms of plague spewing
nurglings but is capable of taking down
chaos Space Marines in a pinch hidden
secrets scattered throughout each level
also provide temporary upgrades that can
boost its damage output such as the
devastatingly explosive Kraken ammo
despite this I never felt like I had to
save certain weapons to the point where
I wouldn't end up using them ammo may
not be especially plentiful but there's
enough to encourage you to bust out the
big guns when dealing with ball guns
most resilient enemies it just makes
sure never to undermine the Bolter which
in turn strengthens the viability of
your entire Arsenal juggling your
Firearms is vitally important when it
comes to dealing with the variety of
enemies that you'll encounter as you
Trek across graya even the weakest
composite threat if they attack in
numbers so strafing judicious use of the
sprint button and perpetual motion are
keys to survival
full guns levels are fairly linear for
the most part but many of its
environments are quite expansive in
between all of the compact Corridor
shooting you'll also uncover these vast
combat areas where you'll be tasked with
purging every enemy before moving on
Space Marines are basically walking
tanks yet you're still surprisingly
Nimble able to fluidly Traverse the
battlefield while maintaining a palpable
sense of weight as your colossal
footsteps vibrate around the room and
shake the screen it's here where you're
assaulted on all sides by all manner of
cultists and Chaos demons from plague
toads which leap around the battlefield
spitting green acid at you to the pink
ores that split into blue Horrors upon
death bulkan is often at its best in
these moments where the exhilaration of
barely surviving by the skin of your
teeth accentuates its thrilling action
unfortunately these combat Arenas also
shine a spotlight on an issue that hits
software saw back in 2016's Doom in true
Boomer shooter fashion the health bar in
bolt gun doesn't replenish over time
instead each level is filled with both
health and armor pickups for you to grab
when the need arises this is par for the
course but being forced to run around
searching for help items and ammo can
take you out of the action for prolonged
periods of time Doom's Glory kills and
Chainsaw rectified this issue and I can
understand why orac digital adopted not
to replicate a feature wholesale but the
old school alternative is inherently
archaic in the tracks from The
Experience some of the levels are also
quite samey making it easy to get turned
around because so many corridors look
almost identical the fact that there's
no map only intensifies this issue
despite these vaults Warhammer 40 000
ball gun is an extremely fun game with a
contagious reverence for classic 90s
Shooters and the Warhammer Universe At
Large its entire arsenal of Flesh
combusting weapons is a joy to use and
its simple gameplay Loop is kept fresh
by the steady supply of new armaments
and enemy types to squash under the
almighty boot of the Imperium it's not
trying to revolutionize the genre and
that's perfectly fine it's the type of
game to hire Avid Warhammer fan Rahul
Kohli to voice its protagonist only to
make him exceptionally easy to miss
unless you stumble upon the taunt button
there aren't any gameplay advantages to
hitting this button but you do get to
hear Coley Relish in delivering some
Space Marine appropriate lines as he
Nails the angry Regal tone and that's
almost worth the price of a mission
alone